et se sont mis à quatre pour essayer de trouver les meilleures personnes possibles,
ne parviennent pas à en tirer le meilleur parti.
Alors, comment peut-on développer les compétences dont nous avons besoin ?
Parce qu'il faut aussi des compétences et de la pratique.
Si nous devons ne pas avoir peur du conflit,
nous devons le considérer comme de la réflexion,
et puis nous devons y devenir vraiment bons.
Récemment, j'ai travaillé avec un cadre qui s'appelle Joe,
et Joe travaillait pour une société d'appareils médicaux.
Et Joe était très préoccupé par l'appareil sur lequel il travaillait.
Il pensait qu'il était trop compliqué
et il pensait que sa complexité
créait des marges d'erreur qui pouvait vraiment blesser des gens.
Il avait peur de faire des dégâts chez les patients qu'il essayait d'aider.
Mais lorsqu'il regardait autour de lui dans son organisation,
personne d'autre ne semblait être inquiet le moins du monde.
Il ne voulait donc vraiment rien dire.
Après tout, peut-être savaient-ils quelque chose qu'il ne savait pas.
Il aurait peut-être l'air stupide.
Mais il a continué à s'inquiéter,
jusqu'à en arriver au point
de penser que la seule chose qu'il pouvait faire
était de quitter un travail qu'il aimait.
Finalement, Joe et moi avons trouvé un moyen
de lui faire connaître ses préoccupations.
Et ce qui est arrivé ensuite est ce qui arrive presque toujours
dans cette situation.
Il s'est avéré que tout le monde avait exactement les mêmes
questions et doutes.
Joe avait donc maintenant des alliés. Ils pourraient réfléchir ensemble.
Et oui, il y a eu beaucoup de conflits, de débats
et de disputes, mais ça a permis de mettre tout le monde autour de la table
de faire preuve de créativité, de résoudre le problème,
et de modifier l'appareil.
Joe était ce que beaucoup de gens considèrent
comme un dénonciateur,
sauf que comme presque tous les dénonciateurs,
Il n'était pas un excentrique,
il se dévouait passionnément à l'organisation
et aux grands objectifs que cette organisation servait.
Mais il avait eu tellement peur du conflit,
jusqu'à ce que finalement il ait encore plus peur du silence.
Et quand il a osé parler,
il a découvert beaucoup plus à l'intérieur de lui-même
et beaucoup plus dans le système qu’il n’avait jamais imaginé.
Et ses collègues ne pensent pas qu'il est excentrique.
Ils pensent qu'il est un leader.
Alors, comment avoir ces conversations plus facilement
et plus souvent ?
L'Université de Delft
impose que ses étudiants en doctorat
soumette cinq déclarations qu'ils sont prêts à défendre.
Peu importe ce que sont les déclarations,
ce qui importe c'est que les candidats soient désireux et capables
de résister à l'autorité.
Je pense que c'est un système fantastique,
mais je pense que de le laisser aux doctorants
représente trop peu de personnes et bien trop tard dans la vie.
Je pense que nous devons enseigner ces compétences
aux enfants et aux adultes à tous les stades de leur développement,
si nous voulons avoir des organisations qui réfléchissent
et une société qui réflichisse.
Le fait est que la plupart des plus grandes catastrophes auxquelles nous avons assisté
proviennent rarement des informations secrètes ou cachées.
Elles viennent des informations librement disponibles
mais que nous sommes volontairement aveugles
parce que nous ne pouvons pas gérer, ne voulons pas gérer,
le conflit qu'elles provoquent.
Mais quand nous osons briser ce silence,
ou lorsque nous osons voir,
et que nous allons au conflit,
nous permettons aux gens autour de nous et à nous-mêmes
de réfléchir de notre mieux.
L'information libre est fantastique,
les réseaux libres sont essentiels.
Mais la vérité ne nous libèrera pas
tant que nous ne développerons pas les compétences, l'habitude, le talent
et le courage moral de l'utiliser.
L'ouverture n'est pas la fin.
C'est le début.
(Applaudissements)